[Music]
now considering this shooting took place
high above an outdoor music venue what's
being done now for future outdoor music
festivals concern is the potential of a
copycat scenario everybody should be
alert and vigilant a few major festivals
are still going forward including Austin
City Limits jay-z the Red Hot Chili
Peppers and more are set to perform
outside this weekend before expected
crowds of 75,000 Austin police are
reviewing security plans festival
organizers were already preparing for
tighter security including restricting
certain bags and instituting full-body
pat-downs the same weekend as that
festival the Foo Fighters and Queens of
the Stone Age will take the stage at
this 65,000 capacity outdoor
amphitheater in California for Cal Jam
17 if you hear a shooting want to run
into inside the nearest a safe building
where you could run hide and take cover
until a uniformed police officer what
gives you the okay to come out and tells
you that it's all safe
today at Sheeran's performance went on
as scheduled outside MTV's Times Square
studios for TRL's return the tragedy
addressed during the shows premiere it's
all about like love and love and unity
and there's not much there's not much
else you can do really
Edie at a loss for words TRL's dj khaled
saying the tragedy hit him hard when I
woke up this morning I was like and
what's going on you know I'm saying and
you know I'm a father now so you know
I'm praying I'm sending my love to all
the families out there and him saying
you know hopefully they can rise up and
overcome this new co-host Tamara dia
telling us that they hope TRL will be a
place of comfort for fans
that's what TRL is it's not just a place
where we talk about music but it's also
a place where we're talking about
real-life events the NYPD tells ET today
security in Times Square has been beefed
up inside TRL other security measures
are also in place the new space which
spans an entire city block will be
equipped with metal detectors and the
movie industry has also been affected by
this tragedy
tonight's Los Angeles premiere of
Marshall with Kate Hudson and sterling K
Brown has been cancelled there will be a
private screening instead
[Music]
you